hey guys thank you so much for tuning in
to another episode of odd man out this
is six married people versus one single
person a big thank you to our sponsor
recon for support in this episode
description link below if you want to
check out these amazing earbuds that
cardi B cannot get enough of okay but
first here's the episode
put your hands out this here with a few
your bands because if you're married
you've got you've got a tan line we
brought together seven married people I
am married I am married I am married I'm
married I am married I am married I am
married one is a liar
if the group discovers who the liar is
they'll split a cash prize if the liar
survives he or she wins the entire prize
[Music]
okay well I think you might be single
I've been married for three years she
targeted me right away she said you are
not married I was like of course it is
how long have you guys been married
quick everybody oh my god I've been
married what years
just two years like last week really one
year I was married this past May so like
four months see I say 50 but if it was
like 50 but does everyone believe that
does everyone believe in traditional
marriage okay the system well wedding
rings all that stuff yeah yeah everybody
yes or no the first thing you have to do
is detail put your hands out let's here
we're just two your bands I thought he
was a little too obvious he was all over
everybody
I'm Bruce really specific I want to know
details quick if you're waiting okay
he's got one I've got one okay does
anyone does everyone have their tan
because if you're married you've got
you've got a tan lines I have a crazy
tan line I have a white band around my
ring finger I thought instead of that
you tell you the day you go oh hold on
hold on I like the Rick he asked you
questions he was putting important
people on blast it was quick it was too
quick it was a good round to observe the
others
one suggestion was made and then there
was 15 seconds left
I personally pounced on it cuz I was
grateful that it wasn't me good luck
very very married what day were you
married cuz I got married October 11
which is my birthday
oh really yeah birthday August 17th is
actually three on our three-year
anniversary
Oh wonderful me and you I got one
question for you now stop no I'm asking
you that question okay what what amber
its 2003 now okay yeah November 7th 2000
okay generally 28th 2017 okay 19 18 not
that anyone asked how long were you
married uh let me see it'll be 30 years
30 years what did you say before this
exactly I was joking with exactly what I
caught to you what was something that
went wrong in your guys's wedding we had
all white wedding everybody wore white
and one lady came in purple and that
would piss me off I believe that she was
not invited my best friend was late to
my wedding and that kind of pissed me
off because I noticed when he were
totally well I have to say there nothing
went wrong ya know we were married in
our home yeah and it just it went so
smoothly
it had me I was actually crying let's
let's look at detail here pay attention
to detail not just the questions look at
detail reactions look it's uh Mike I'm
here to win so I want I want to make
sure everyone you're the lawyer of all
people a lot of manipulation I do class
actions plaintiff side guys
maybe it's the guy with a fanny pack and
all these props thank you very much and
always remember the obvious is always
your worst enemy if you don't pay
attention to detail always remember that
it's about illumination at the right
time and it just it ran out for me
I felt like we got the wrong guy out I
was like we still have candies in here
there's something about candies I come
from that institution so we don't
believe in divorce you know we don't
divorce our husbands we bury them that's
what my mother said Candace was you know
she was out there
how old is your significant other my
husband is 35 and you are I'm 55 okay
what's up like a small detail about your
wife that you love that differs her from
your others and my aunt's first thing
that I saw were her legs even it might
be so you asked the first thing and I'm
telling you all your other wives legs
yeah and and she was no no yes let me
tell you and that's what surprised and
everything else worked out fine she said
things that we're confusing to me like
she said that her husband was 35 but
they'd been married for 30 years and so
I was like so your husband was five when
you married him
where you just have to like off the top
of your head before we do that can we
see the hands again yes yo mine's like
yeah you're the only one that doesn't
really happen no I don't why don't you
worry I never have I don't wear a ring
so I figured the best thing to do is of
course tell them that maybe that's again
why it hasn't worked out too well for me
in the past no no I'm on three I think
get it covered though if you're the
color I have always loved marriage I
believe in the institution strongly it
would be unfair to face the decision
solely on oh you don't have a tan line
there's a lot of reasons why someone
might not wear a ring okay I'm not gonna
lie I'm so suspicious of everyone oh
yeah hey you know what's funny if we're
gonna talk about who we see but I think
you two are suspicious cuz you asking
all the questions and asking I'm an
attorney like why I'm trying those
questions like you asking me all this
question but you asking her any
questions I think you might be
suspicious you like any question you
want
in the next 47 seconds how does it move
one year September and u18 yeah my
husband's 27 he's turning 28 on October
11 another cougar huh something off
right there so started in a head up
he believed in traditional marriage she
believed everything about marriage but
he never thought about wearing a ring
I'm like having no assumption
I guess I saw that coming
good luck you guys thank you I was like
happy to stop there
I once all went out because I'm like I
think I'm comforting us three and we're
gonna split the money so you were
captain but he persuade you basic yeah
she felt that way and I'm not gonna lie
I feel like when I started asking you
questions you got really defensive and
trying to push back I just figured that
I do really think that you are married
but how do you stop this I just made
this up thank you but that's why I put
my head up with I believe in you guys
and now you guys related
I have much regret about having
initiated the vote oh my god you have
treated me I'll never trust another
woman again
I would still just relieved that Ali
didn't like jump up and be like just
kidding it's me thank God I know towards
the end I was like well you can't tell a
book by its cover
I've been married three times it just
didn't quite work out for me and now I'm
observing the three-strike rule no more
marriages I felt some regret with all of
the other people who had been voted out
but I also felt pretty good about
winning I wanted without the money well
you know I really want to have fun I
says so let me see if I can do a
different kind of strategy maybe lie a
little bit mix them in with the truth
cuz I figured well maybe I could catch
the mole but uh
good game really good game Oh
that episode just reminded me how single
I am but you know maybe Saul will want
to go on a date with me you could be
number four I would like that and big
thank you to our sponsor gray Khan for
sponsoring this episode check out these
amazing wireless earbuds and they start
at just half the price of other premium
wireless earbuds on the market but they
sound just as amazing all right let's
get this going their latest model the
e25 is their best one yet when you open
them up they pair immediately out of the
case super compact very discreet or as
we say in Boston wicked small gonna fit
the entire case in the palm of my hand
and you can charge them with the case
too they come in all sorts of awesome
colors black being my favorite there is
six hours of playback time and a
noise-isolating fit so it's no wonder
that cardi B and Snoop are blues s with
them so check out the link in the
description box below for 15% off your
order
as always guys thank you so much for
watching make sure
follow us on instagram subscribe leave a
comment below and we will see you next
time where do you say
can't hear you there noise isolating
[Music]